what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i have a
special guest on the channel
we have a olympian how cool is that
you're living my out my dream thank you
for having me pearl i have to do this
joke the black pearl this one's my
favorite joke sorry the black prop
caribbean um parts of the caribbean i
don't know
but thank you for having me thank you
for coming um before i start guys do not
forget to subscribe to the channel and
ring that notification bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos you guys already know if you have
watched three or more of my lives and
you don't subscribe me and you we have
what beef okay beef
or beef and there you go
tell them how it is
um
okay so tell me
you played in the 2012 olympics
i did you see well it is a long time ago
it's like 10 years this summer
um but yeah i was 22
i think straight out of college which
was great so i played in america in
florida and graduated and went straight
to the olympic games
but trained pretty much maybe like three
years it's not an overnight thing of
like oh i want to go to the olympics and
then the next day it's like
a couple years process
a full year like really committing i
didn't drink eat sweets or
all that
um
can i swear on this yeah
i have a mouthful of a sailor but i'm
just like
um
so yeah no i i really committed to it
obviously great britain we each if you
host the olympics they can have a team
you can have whatever you want but we
actually qualified by right um through
all the qualifications so
yeah it was a bit crazy and it's just a
really fun time in my life so how when
did you start playing basketball
um
i started when i was like 12 or 13 maybe
like year 8 which is english secondary
school
or high school like sophomore year
um
and yeah so i played netball first and
then i played basketball and really got
into it loved it in fact um but i was
terrible so i'm six foot four and i was
about this height by i was 16 so i just
kind of had to learn to grow into my
body and
what i could do what i couldn't do but i
was [ __ ] at first really you kind of
started on american
like timeline that's kind of late
yes that's very late well
uh
england we don't really play basketball
so you don't start from young there's
not really many young up and coming um
like you know uh camps or anything now
it's probably better
but yeah i did start quite late
when when you look at it like that so
when did you come to the us
16 so that was kind of early in the fact
of like leaving home
so i left home at 16 i
moved away from my family i told my
parents i was like yeah i want to be a
basketball player i'm gonna go um and so
i moved to virginia for three years
found a host family
yeah it was it was fun it was so good um
but yeah i took it really seriously
until
yeah and until 22 when you actually so
how does it work so do
they do they find you to come to the
olympics or do you have to like try out
no no no because you were you had to
have been on their radar yeah yeah no no
no yeah i was part of i'm still part of
the great britain team so you're part of
the national team and then obviously
there's a there's a big group of 14 to
16 players and then they only take 12.
so i was i've been with them for a very
long time i've been playing for great
britain for
12 years maybe yeah 13 years
how i would be so sad if i was at 13.
you probably know the 13. i do very well
yeah devastated yeah it was
heartbreaking really it really is
heartbreaking it's a moment where
obviously your dreams have come true and
somebody else are really good friends
hasn't and so it's like this really
rollercoaster moment but that's life in
general right lots of things go your way
and sometimes it doesn't so
yeah it was really tough um
she worked her ass off but it was good
it was a great um
and to play the olympics in london
for my family obviously i'm from london
to come to yeah remember
to come to stratford around the corner
really yeah it was amazing so all my
family came
um i had five games like basketball is a
tournament in the olympics where like
boxing if you lose your first fight the
first night your olympic games is over
and then you just start partying but
with um basketball it's a five game
tournament and then it goes to the semis
for you know what i mean court fighters
by the way finals so you've got five
games so you you're in it for good solid
ten days um
so
that was
a lot because it's all you can eat sorry
we'll move back i was wrong no
she wanted me to sound sexy and then
like
they said it was too much in the
comments i was like
sorry guys i guess i was wrong thanks
she wanted me up close
um yeah so
that was it really we just were in
olympic games for it's like a two and a
half week tournament we were there the
whole time um
everything you can think of i got
questions yes go ahead because ever i'm
sure everyone there's a million podcasts
talking about like what you did at the
olympics right yeah millions i saw the
articles and stuff like that yeah go on
then but i want i want to know the juicy
details okay
do you guys like party and like does
everyone hook up at the olympics that's
that's what's the question
yeah is that your question yeah yeah
because i i can't imagine like you're
bringing the most attractive people like
on the planet into one place i mean
it's inevitable right
um the hottest sexiest people
in one space
um myself i did not hook up with anyone
so i totally regret it
but um
was there anyone that you had a chance
at that yeah
yeah i did actually i had two um
but
listen it's
very hot they're very sexy both women
and men
there's usually you live in the same
building so like the same um country
lives in the same block so you've got
usa in one block you've got australia in
one block but then you'll go outside on
your balcony and there'll be like a hot
swimmer or something like you know just
glistening and you're like oh hello um
but i think a lot of people it's a
serious moment right it's sure it comes
every four years so you have to stay
really focused and then once you do lose
or you finish or if you win then it's
time to party where i have heard of
stories where kind of more like
poorer countries come and then they eat
it's all you can eat and they eat
their their work out away you know so
all they party and just get distracted
but
it is a very fun environment especially
if you win then you've got your medal
and you can rock up to any bar a
restaurant in london and they let you in
and obviously you're drinking partying
whatever
um but yeah it is
they hand out condoms at the end of the
party so safe sex is definitely the way
they're trying to promote
um but then you would have like a golden
baby imagine if you had a baby with
whoever you wanted to yeah then it's
like elite jeans but anyway yeah i came
out
uh pregnant free was there any um was
there any famous people that like shot
their shot at you
like that that people would know
that would get me in trouble
yeah that would get me in trouble but i
got a lot of shots fired and i had a
boyfriend at the time and i just really
don't suggest having a boyfriend you
definitely need a hall pass through the
olympic games because i was good i got
lots of like offers hey hey and i was
like i have a boyfriend yeah and it's
just not a good idea so i don't know if
that's allowed but i wish i did or broke
up with him or
yeah so it was the boyfriend then your
then husband no okay no no no no so
he's gone too so
i'm a free woman um no so
you obviously it's it's a beautiful
place like everywhere you look at even
like
the big guys or the big girls or skinny
girl like everyone's beautiful you know
the gymnasts are tiny but they're so
cute and so it's a lot of attractive
people in one space but yes i think it
does pop off but it didn't pop off for
me
that's a missed opportunity
i truly regret it i banter with my
friends all the time saying what an
opportunity i missed
um but yeah now i missed it and if i if
i went to another olympic games and i
had a boyfriend uh i
might ask for a whole pass
wait one some so did you go was that the
only one you went to or yeah i say only
but that's still like crazy yeah i went
to that one and then i went to the
commonwealth games in australia okay
which was kind of
a smaller environment but they put on
like a really great show and
lots of
fantastic people there too so yeah how
did you guys do like how did you guys
make it so we didn't make it out of the
first round so that really sucked but we
lost to um france in overtime by three
and they won the silver medal so
that is as close as we kind of got um
but it was good it was really
then we were really a small
up-and-coming country like we had when
we're new
um to basketball where america
all of europe have 50 60 years on us and
we've probably got like 15 years
so
yeah we really tried to strive and put
ourselves on the map you know
was it
was it kind of annoying to you that you
guys had to play france first round
because you probably would have made it
further i'm assuming if you played
someone else i'd be irritated no no it's
like a pool so it's kind of hard you
have to get through but
i prefer to play them because we didn't
have usa in our group right if you've
got usa in your group you're not making
it to the next round pretty much
so but they were all tough games we
played um
the russians french
canadians brazilians and the aussies
so yeah it was tough all tough games
so okay i have another question okay go
ahead you're trying to get me in trouble
aren't you no
i just i just don't know if i can i need
a couple more drinks
i just have
yeah i just don't know if i can let out
secrets like this do you know i mean
i'll get in trouble go ahead okay okay
so another question yes this is what
i've noticed it's kind of tough because
so i'm 25 right
and i'm looking at possibly playing pro
volleyball in like germany next year
yeah and it's kind of tough because you
sort of have to pick between if you want
to like start a family
have a career yeah or be a professional
or be a pro athlete yeah um so
what made you pick athlete
uh
i picked it for a long time like i
didn't even get my first boyfriend was
pretty much 19 years old so i i bloomed
late anyway but i really committed to
the game like my family pretty much
thought i was playing for the same team
let's be honest because i didn't have a
boyfriend yet and i was like guys
basketball is what i'm doing um
and how did i pick it's more just like
trying to find a balance of
and even now i'm still learning i feel
like i'm bringing
work home like so
i'm the not the captain but the leader
right the veteran i'm 33 so i've got a
few more years on you um and how i live
my life on the court and then i'm
starting to bring it into my
relationships and i just trying to find
that balance but
i did take a break i retired like you
said i i did get married and i wanted
that family life and basketball wasn't
for me anymore you know
and i just didn't love it and when you
don't love it you start to cheat on it
so
but then um i
finished that and then i started
basketball again and starting to love it
but trying to find a balance is tough
but anything that you want you find time
right but
the thing is being an athlete is
multiple hours in but then there's a lot
of hours off you're just super tired um
so yeah right now i'm finding a nice
balance of
family friends love life being a pro
like i think i've got a nice
good good lifestyle and um are you
dating anyone now i am meeting somebody
yeah so i got i got more questions okay
yeah so you're if you guys can't tell on
camera um she makes me look short so i'm
six foot she's six four which i love i
don't know about you i love being tall i
love it too i wouldn't change it for
anything like i'm always just i feel
like a model well i feel like in
especially this day and age of like
instagram and all this stuff like
everyone's trying to stick out and
everyone's the same where high
you're instantly different yeah there's
not that many six foot four people
your height like so as soon as you walk
into a room they're like wow and so i
can
embrace a whole i can like make a room
all look at me but it's more the fact of
now how do you handle that you know can
you are you comfortable in it a long a
lot of years i was so like shy and like
no but now i'm like yes honey
she's here you know but it's that fine
line of like
you know just being confident and really
loving your height
well and i saw a video guy so everyone
knows on the channel i don't i'm sorry
i'm sorry to the short kings out there
yeah i don't i don't talk to guys that
are like below 5 10. why
i just can't i can't get with it i can't
i
it's superficial and it's shallow
i just can't help it okay i'm not really
attracted to guys shorter than me
but you love a tall king or a short king
i love them but i i don't i don't um
discriminate no no i've had short and
i've had tall
right now the guy i'm seeing is shorter
than me
yeah five inches shorter than me
five eleven yeah five eleven okay and
you just don't it's funny right like you
wake up in the morning and you don't go
oh my god i'm six foot four
you know don't i'm six foot four that's
it i don't every day it's the same thing
and when you're in a relationship it's
not it you don't see it like my i have
friends who are five foot they don't go
oh my god it's not until somebody
outside of your bubble goes oh my god
you're so tall or like uh like you know
and makes you go oh oh yeah [ __ ] i'm six
foot four so it's not until somebody
does that yeah
is when you realize and the same with
when i'm with him like it's not until
somebody looks
but he loves you if you're gonna date
shorter he has to be like quite
you know
confident and doesn't care finds it sexy
quite he's gotta be
um short guys love oh
honey the guys that come at me the most
i think short guys chat me up more than
tour guys because i think tall guys
think like we should be together yeah
where i can't like with a short guy i'm
so confident and cocky with a talker i
can't even look at him i'm like we he
thinks that we should be like
talking to each other right now i can't
do it i just get so like nope
i don't know why so so what's the was
your ex-husband taller than you
yes foot
six okay yeah so he was and he was big
yeah it was a big dominant like he made
me look tired like look tiny but the guy
that i'm seeing right now makes me feel
tiny like he makes me feel like a lady
and a woman and cute so what's the
difference
oh there's no difference like i think
it's good for women to date shorter i i
just don't have you tried
not really i mean i've stayed in my
height but i've never dated like a lot
shorter but i know the numbers behind
stuff okay i know i know too much about
dating it's like bad it ruins it a
little bit
um because i talk about that on this
platform so what percent of men do you
think are over six foot
not a lot yeah probably isn't the like
average height five nine maybe five
eight five ten five ten okay so not a
lot it's like 15 oh [ __ ] so so it's like
if you have something else you look for
like say work ethic income certain
levels of attractive if you go for guys
over six foot it's like one
more competition yeah more competitive
and then smaller so from i'm like a
numbers person okay it's like smart to
date shorter right because it's a bigger
pool right
but i always say right like
can he hold your hand when you're upset
can he rub your back when you're sick
can he
hug you and kiss you and you go to bed
yes what's that gotta do with height
yeah nothing nothing so what is the big
you know what i mean like i don't think
there's a big deal i just can't like i
don't look at a couple and think
anything i just can't do it
we were we actually went out the other
it was my birthday we were out and
another woman uh had a short guy he
wasn't that much sure he was probably
like one or two inches but she they
weren't looking the guys and she just
caught my eye and she was like just
looked at me like
and i was like
if you heard the tic tac sound the girls
like get it get it no oh are you no no
i'm not on tick tock sorry
but you can sing it for me if you want
oh it's just it's a sound it's like the
girl's like get it get it and the girl's
like don't don't okay that's exactly it
she got it and she was with it so i'm
with it
i don't mind i'm not i'm not uh
i'm not against anything i don't really
have a type
just like
a black guy for me is my thing yeah like
just sexy that's all i like well it's
funny because um
that's what and so a lot of my audience
is men so they'll always say like oh
girls don't go for guys under a certain
height and i'm like i don't there's a
certain type like certain girls don't
care
i have a six foot six friend who won't
though and she i've been like
really kind of like no come on you need
to success yeah and she won't like she's
very like you like nope don't do short
guys but then if the have you seen like
super tall guys going with short girls
like you know what i mean so okay so
then the short girls are taking all the
tall guys like that back to your
percentage yeah there aren't a lot out
there for us to have i don't i don't
know if you've found this but i found so
if a guy's like six three six four okay
he likes girls that are like five five
why is that if a guy if a guy is like
six six
six seven six eight six ten
then
he likes me or like taller bit like
taller girls i'm this is just what i
found if you found that to be true yeah
i feel stupid so yeah you always see
like the little [ __ ] girlfriends like
why would you want to break your neck
every day to like you would probably
just pick her up and kiss her and then
put her down though that's what i would
do i think it's because i don't know i
think they like girls that make them
feel bigger maybe but you're already
massive mate like you don't need to feel
any bigger like i'm not sure but yeah i
don't know i don't really discriminate
and i'm a fan i like short my first ever
boyfriend was super short so maybe
that's where it came from when i was
like 14 15 years old i think the
shortest i've ever dated is like five
nine five ten yeah no sure for me i
think mine was like five
seven that was when i was young five
seven yeah this this one i'm seeing now
is five ten five five ten five eleven
yeah
interesting
gonna read actually hold on did you get
some questions yeah i did yeah um but
actually can i can i ask you about your
marriage or no yes sure so you did i
said before that she was living out my
dream
so you dated an nfl player you married
an nfl player i did yeah what what is it
like
um
it's not what it's cracked up to be i
think it's made like especially like
with wags and stuff like that it's it's
been kind of really glamorized
is that even a word i don't know um and
it's hard you know it's tough because
um the season is really a struggle you
know they're beat up they're coming home
super tired they're on the road
depends if you're
you know nfl they're one a week but nba
they're they could be on a 10 12 day
road trip and you don't see them you
know they could get cut and you're
living in one city and then the next day
you get up and move your whole family
like it's not fun it's not fun at all i
think the the people what see as dream
is just like the money part but money
really i was the richest i've ever been
and wasn't happy you know so i think if
the money part is like oh my god yeah
but
you could be with somebody else ceo of
something else could be rich you know so
that's what so when i say it's my dream
i always think like you'd get to meet
and go to such cool places yeah like did
you enjoy that or was it just not worth
it to you um
see i
in the humblest way like i'm my own
celebrity too yeah like so i was
already i had my own career i had my own
fame if you want like okay it's not huge
beyonce but i ha i i had been a part of
all these different circles so i had
met a lot of people already um and then
obviously together we were quite like a
power couple in england like he was the
best in england and i was too so for us
to to be together we were like the
british beyonce and jay-z yes wait so i
thought he was an nfl was he not in the
u.s he's english oh he was english what
was he wait he played in the nfl or no
oh sorry it was english did you guys
move there he had gone already and i
moved yeah because i retired but
everyone thinks he's american he's
english
oh i didn't know that yes so we were
both english and yeah it was
i mean it was fun i had my own season so
i was playing too
um i think a lot of women who i still
have friends really dedicate their lives
to their part to their partner who's in
season you know and don't really have
much for themselves and so it is quite
him and him only where i had a lot
to do i was still doing a lot of myself
and still i lost myself in him as well
um
when i retired well that's actually
i had a very similar experience yeah
because my last boyfriend had like a
very big following
and i just found myself like
like always like i feel like i lost a
lot of my hobbies because i was just
like always doing like what he wanted to
do going where he wanted to go you know
what i mean yeah and i also i couldn't
deal with the girls all the time i
couldn't like because you just know that
like there's always girls in their dms
yeah i i don't know about you for me it
was like
hard to handle
yeah i think um you have to find a
respect right because as much as he had
girls and dms i had guys at my dms
sliding you know
um so i think it's a respectful thing i
think it's
make sure you have boundaries um and set
the tone of what what are we doing are
we committing are we an open
relationship are we
you know so i think a lot of it is
communication because
oh who's here to see us
we're on pause guys
we've got friends joining
i feel like twitch loves this when they
run out of the screen no it's fine it's
chill
um
yeah so
that's it really and he's happy and i'm
happy and
yeah there's no beef between us it's
just nice we went our separate ways and
he's doing his thing and i'm doing mine
yeah
okay i gotta end it on this because the
people are coming in okay no worries but
thanks for coming on guys we're doing a
live show in like
30 and probably 45 minutes i'm gonna be
honest 30 45 minutes
so come on um and watch then but thank
you for coming on i appreciate it i'll
be in the next part right yeah okay